with Doctor Who coming to Disney Plus in
2023 what can this mean for the future
of the show does it mean shows like
Torchwood could potentially return
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so as you know I made a video last week
on Doctor Who basically telling you
about the fact that it's going to be on
Disney Plus in 2023 now I've been
thinking does this mean that we're going
to potentially be getting some spin-off
series as a result of this now there is
some logic behind why I think this but
honestly I absolutely hope we do you may
have already seen my YouTube short where
I basically posited the question will we
get spin-off series as a result of the
Disney plus and BBC partnership and I've
been really thinking about this because
honestly I think it's just such a
no-brainer to have more spin-off series
and expand the Doctor Who Universe think
about it Disney love a universe think
about what happened with Marvel they
extended the Marvel Universe into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe which then had
TV shows and movies and massive huge
crossover events such as Infinity war
and end game those were an absolutely
amazing and lots of other properties are
actually doing something very similar
now but how's that going to work with a
property like Doctor Who who's
historically have only had a handful of
spin-off shows what have we had so far
we've had Torchwood we've had the
adventures of canine back in back in the
day
we had the Sarah Jane Adventures for
CBBC the kids show and we had class
which was aimed at a younger audience
trying to get them into Doctor Who as
well there were a few unofficial
spin-offs like we had the Peter Cushing
Doctor Who movies and a handful of
parodies for things like comic relief
you can consider those spin-offs in a
way but I think there could be so much
more done with Doctor Who it's such a
huge and vast universe
think about Torchwood for example
Torchwood was a fantastic show it was
tailored to a much older audience it was
basically Doctor Who for adults and it
was absolutely fantastic if it was ever
going to come back I would be absolutely
ecstatic if John Barrowman came back to
re reclaim his his role as Captain Jack
Harkness
yes fantastic do it I would like to see
that on my screen yesterday make it
happen but here's how I think it could
actually work
so we could have a few spin-off series
is running co-currently to Doctor Who
and it would all be distributed through
Disney plus so we could have a new
series of tortured for example we should
run kind of at the same time as Doctor
Who maybe earlier on in the year or
later on in the year depending on when
Doctor Who is going to fall in their
schedule we could have a kids version of
Doctor Who much like the Sarah Jane
Adventures running it's on on the kids
side of Disney Plus on Disney kids but
for the main fans for the people who
have grown up watching Doctor Who like
me we can have more series we can have a
series based on Missy you know the
master we can have a series based on the
adventures of the master Missy which
would be absolutely fantastic there
could be a much more serious drama uh
centered around unit unit HQ there could
be stories for characters that we
haven't seen in a long time we could see
stories about the time War Companions of
old could come back
and have their own shows because we
because we know that what happens when
you travel with the doctor as soon as
you leave that Adventure doesn't leave
and those companions go on to do amazing
things but we never actually get to see
them this gives the opportunity to make
it so we can finally see what happens
when you leave the doctor going back to
the idea of a series about the time War
we could potentially have a series
leading up to that starring Paul McGann
who In fairness never got his fair
chance of being the doctor he had one
movie in the 90s he was the doctor in
the Doctor Who movie and since then he's
only had two appearances one in Night of
the doctor and the second appearance in
the very recent power of the doctor but
we've never had him as the doctor an
actual adventure and and discounting big
Finnish audio books here because I'm
just speaking primarily about things
that we see on screen boomgan does have
now a series of him you know as as the
doctor in audio form which is great but
I want to see it on the screen we can
have one-off specials as well very much
like what we had with Torchwood where we
had uh Miracle Day which was a fantastic
one off special actually the very very
last time we ever saw Torchwood
um
which always makes me sad and is one of
the reasons why I want Torchwood to come
back but you know how they had Miracle
day as one cohesive story and then more
recently they've had flux they could do
that with lots and lots of different
serieses going on and all
interconnecting and being part of the
same universe and I think it would be
absolutely fantastic but you know what I
think would be even better than having
spin-off series
having all of those
but also finally getting a proper High
budget
Doctor Who movie using the same actors
not doing what DC do where they have a
TV show full of actors and then the
movie is separate actors no no the same
actors in a movie A Doctor Who movie
released in the cinemas not for a
special like the 50th Anniversary was a
full-fledged Cinema release
would be absolutely fantastic and it
would be something that would absolutely
make my life I've never seen Doctor Who
on the big screen I had the chance to
see it in the on the 50th anniversary
special and I didn't go
but I would absolutely love to see it
because for me Doctor Who is up there
with the greatest science fiction uh
television shows of all time Doctor Who
is up there with things like Star Wars
and Stargate for me
Doctor Who is up there with like Star
Trek it could be as good if it if it was
made into a movie and now that Disney is
invested in it as well and is going to
be investments from them to give higher
production costs and things like that
the future of Doctor Who is looking so
bright and I'm super excited about it
but what I really want to know is what
you think do you like any of the ideas
that I've said do you agree with me that
this would be amazing or do you think it
would kill Doctor Who let me know what
you think and if you are new to the
YouTube channel hit subscribe and whilst
you're down there hit the Bell
notification so you don't miss a single
video also consider becoming a fully
flagged side tracker by pressing the
join button down below
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay safe and I will see you next week
[Music]